all right good afternoon everybody thank
you all for coming out today I also want
to point out that this is actually a
joint meetup with the Ann Arbor re2 ml
group those Democrats little runs a
group you guys okay so yeah join in our
machine learning meetup if you haven't
joined it already also we have a
community-wide slack called a two meds
that slack whatever there is a self sign
up so if you sign up for the machine
learning meetup then you'll get a it as
part of the welcome email you'll get the
self sign on the link for that as well
somebody needs it and doesn't have it
already for some reason just catch up
with me afterward awesome
so a couple of things obviously
acknowledgments we like to acknowledge
numb focus for sponsoring this the
meetup group itself TD Ameritrade for
sponsoring not only their time but also
the space that you're inhabiting also
spark for helping out also Midas Midas
is a is a great resource that is
sponsoring the food here so make sure
that you see someone University of
Michigan people say thank you alright
and also another great thing too is as a
pie data and Arbor group we have
recently eclipsed over 500 members of
our group in short six months which is
fantastic
it helps justifying the in the long term
running a PI data conference here in Ann
Arbor which I hopefully people will sign
up and take part in and also even for
this for this particular meetup we think
we had combined about 160 people
register for this event
so thank you again for your continued
interest and support also again for
people that are
new here this is the standard preamble
emergency exits there's one right here
and there's one right outside the door
to your right okay so if anything
happens please use the stairs again
we're always looking for speakers so if
you your local I work for a company
we're at the University come tell us and
share your data story it doesn't always
have to be data success even failure
it's a good for us to learn from
workshops Marcus is still working on on
putting together workshop for us but if
you have any feedback in general whether
it's about workshops about how we are
organizing this event how we can improve
and be better please definitely reach
out to us also everything that we do is
stored on our github page so go and
check that out and unless you have quick
short questions please try to hold them
at the end so that we can get through
our talk quickly and again we're in a
bore with space so please be respectful
and clean up after yourselves so all of
your your plates and your cups please
help out as always I'd like to read the
PI unit code of conduct especially for
our new members here so PI data is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race or religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communication should be
appropriate for a professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meet
up events be kind to others do not
insult a put-down other attendees behave
professionally remember remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for par data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave by the leave
the meet up at the sole discretion of
the meetup organizers but overall it's
just thank you for making this a
welcoming and friendly event for
everybody
I assume that everybody will do good
again we'd like to do a quick icebreaker
because at these events it's good for
networking
so today's icebreaker is turn to one of
your neighbors introduce yourself and
tell them what you're listening to
either music podcasts anything audio so
turn to your neighbor and share please
go ahead
what are you listening
the one who is coming it was not
recorded
[Music]
so of course we'd like to mention our
sort of data science story of the month
so as you all may or may not know there
was recently PI data Seattle but there
is upcoming up high data in New York
City which TD Richard happens to be one
of the diamond sponsors for but it's a
November 27th to 30th go sign up limited
spots and they're gonna fill up really
really quickly and it's the Monday after
Thanksgiving in case that matters so go
check it out also we'd like to remind
people that all riley is generous enough
to offer one of these free ebooks they
can go download if you visit this link
up here alright calm slash pub slash get
PI data and Arbor you can give provide
your email address and they'll send you
or they'll give you access to one of
these books again this is on our github
page Haggadah Ann Arbor so don't be
concerned about missing and also always
tweet at us at party data Ann Arbor or
you can find us on on Gmail just a
couple of announcements TD Ameritrade is
hiring if I can have the analytics Co e
people part of the TD Ameritrade please
put up a hand or something so people can
see you it may be in the back so visit
one of one of these these folks here
their team is hiring whether it's data
scientist data analyst make sure you
talk to them right also on the advanced
analytics team here in Ann Arbor they're
in the back there
they're also hiring I think a Java Java
developer and also on my team on the
advanced technology team we're looking
for senior folks on the research and
development side and a separate
announcement for stock X grew over here
if you want to talk to him I think it's
based out of Detroit yeah we're sure
so they're hiring a group of people from
VP update data size data analyst VI
analyst product catalog specialists and
data engineers and here's some of the
information so be la blah blah blah and
then move at Starcom but again you can
find us
on our github page which will post
afterwards and any other anybody else
have job postings if they would like to
share even don't have it now you can
always reach out to me and I'll add it
to our deck in the future and of course
the next event is with Brian Witherspoon
from dual security
so somebody local here and the title of
their talk is biggish data scaling up
customer facing lives and it's not too
far away Thursday September 14th same
time same place and so with that I'd
like to introduce our speaker of today
so this is Sebastian Raska from Michigan
State University right now so you might
have you might know Sebastian from from
being a Amazon best-selling author is
that correct his book on machine
learning in Python and the second
edition is about to come out but also
Sebastian currently is a senior graduate
student at Michigan State University and
he was recently earlier than a year won
an award for the biochemistry Department
as I guess graduate student of the year
of the years I should say and being a
former graduate of that same department
it is not and is not awarded every year
so this is a huge accomplishment and
amongst amongst those accomplishments
you will probably have seen a lot of
great things that Sebastian has done and
we're very fortunate that he's here
today to talk about tensorflow so would
you mind all giving a sebastien around
applause
[Applause]
yeah hi everyone thank you for attending
and thanks for the nice introduction
Sean he was actually in the same
department as I was but I think he left
a few years earlier before I started but
I saw some posters in the hallway
mention his name and yeah thanks for
coming and I hope my talk won't be as
long as Sean's but I think maybe
something interesting to present here
honestly I've never given a talk and
tensorflow and I should mention I don't
want to over advertise anything but I
have found it very useful in one of my
recent projects I'm collaborating with a
biometrics group at MSU where we work on
also computation of computer vision
problems and I found it incredibly
useful for that project where we build
our own kind of neural network
architectures and with that I just like
to introduce it to you because you know
deep learning is kind of a hype or maybe
over hype right now and this is just a
little tool that helps you to make use
of this technology of deep learning
maybe applying it to your projects and
with that maybe let me start and so
there will be a kind of I mean I tried
to not include too many code snippets
because it's not really like a hands-on
tutorial where we execute code and stuff
like that but there will be some code
snippets so I put a Jupiter notebook
here on github that if you like to check
out the code if you want to revisit
things later it's all on there and also
the slides are on speaker deck just
uploaded them I think yesterday sometime
in the evening and yeah so then let's
just start talking about tensor flow I'm
not sure how many people have used
tensor flow here Oh quite a bit I hope
it won't be too introductory then so 10
so floor for those who haven't used it
yet it's basically a library that helps
you to perform linear algebra operations
like matrix multiplications but it has
also a lot of things that help you with
deep learning like predefined functions
power functions that make everything a
little bit more convenient has been open
sourced in November 2015
it's not in my book which was just
published like a few months earlier
where I still used Theon which are also
found useful and the reason why I use
tends to floss mainly I think it was
Christmas break I needed some something
to play with I checked it out I really
liked it and I used it then in my future
project and yet that is the white paper
with a lot of information about why
pencil or how they build it and all the
kind of details it evolved quite a bit
though its 2017 now and it's version 1.3
now so it's a lot more mature now than
it was back then and also there are a
lot of contributions from the
open-source community improving it
making it faster adding new features
it's a pretty cool project or it has
become a really big project as well and
yeah maybe just to start with the name
tensorflow
white and source or what are ten source
so the name tensorflow
it kind of indicates cancers are like a
mathematical object to represent scalars
vectors matrices it's a generalization
of the term for example we can say a
scale a single number would be a rank
one ring zero tenths or a vector rank
one tensor matrix a rank two tensor and
if we stack multiple matrices that would
be ranked three ten so we usually in
practice use terms like matrices and
vectors and say tensor if we have
anything that is has more dimensions
than a matrix because we don't have a
special term for that anymore
and yeah so and you can also think about
it if it sounds fancy tensors and stuff
but I mean if you've used numpy the
multi-dimensional arrays it's exactly
the same thing so multi-dimensional
arrays are basically data structures to
represent tensors the mathematical
object and just quickly uh installing
tensor flow because there's something I
want to get it in a second
so it's a pretty empty slide which maybe
indicates it's pretty easy to install
it's maybe not the whole truth
so on my left up for example I just pip
install tensor flow I have the CPU
version it works perfectly fine I run
the code on my laptop to debug flow to
develop code but ultimately we want
to run stuff on the GPU and there you
can also then install the GPU version
and that takes a little bit more of a
setup
regarding other libraries by Nvidia I
like CUDA and Q DNN but there's a good
guide out there on the tensorflow dot
orc install I also have put together a
PDF on how to set it up on Amazon I
personally I sometimes use Amazon if I
run Jupiter on notebooks but usually we
have the HPCC at msu which I just where
I just a prototype my code on my laptop
and then submit it by our PBS script to
the HPCC and a nice nice thing about
tensorflow is you don't have to do
anything anything extra to run your code
on a GPU or CPU especially you just
submit your script and it will run and
the cool thing about GPUs then is why do
we care about GPUs because for
operations that can be easily
parallelized it's a lot faster and it's
just a chart or table I put together our
like a few weeks ago and maybe it's a
little bit unfair because I took a
high-end very expensive CPU but usually
you can see at a let's say similar price
point in general you get a lot of more
performance out of the GPU if you have
operations that support it for example
or linear algebra operations and things
like that and one of these things would
be for example just a matrix
multiplication so to talk a little bit
of vectorization when we write it's a
deep learning application of machine
learning we try to vectorize our code so
that means that we want to take
advantage of operations that can be run
in parallel removing for loops and
things like that so if you think about
it if you have these two matrices for
example here that in the rows that could
be your training examples in the columns
that could be your features and then you
multiply it by a matrix then this first
row here if you multiply it with this
one it's basically just a multiplication
of each element you multiply this one
with this one this one and this one this
one in this one and then if you've done
this five times you compute the sum of
the
terms and then you get this value here
and you don't have to wait til this
finishes when you compute the next
column to get this value for example
with the first row you can run this in
parallel you can take advantage
operation and CPUs are also pretty good
at that there's the SIMD the single
instruction multiple data thing in GPUs
but GPUs are really even much better at
that and just to show you an example to
get back to vectorization matrix matrix
multiplication I can also write it out
and Python here like I have actually
three for loops over the training
examples let's say I want to compute
activations for a hidden layer I have a
weight matrix that is in features times
and hidden or a number of hidden units
and I could just write this follow up
iterate over the training examples and
the columns of my white matrix and then
for the back vector dot product I would
compute or I have another for loop and
we can just do this simply with one
operation using linear algebra by
computing the matrix multiplication
using for example here in amp I would
give the exact same result and so we can
do this enough time but with tensor flow
it's even more efficient because we can
take advantage of GPUs which is
especially useful if we have deep neural
networks and to get back to tens of lono
so tensorflow has these computation
graphs and this is a screenshot from a
figure from the paper actually and so
maybe explain for those who have used
tensor flow yet to kind of introduce how
we think we have to think about
computation graphs when we write our
code it's a little bit different from
native Python and numpy so in the next
few slides I'm going to talk about
computation graphs more so how we what
it means and how we work with them so
let's say we have a simple function that
could be that's an activation function
we have multiplication here like let's
say weight times the feature form a
training example plus a bias unit
and a real active ation function it's
just a very very simple function could
be one hidden activation in our neural
network and for those who haven't worked
with realms that's just a rectified
linear unit that looks like this so what
it just basically means is if our input
is larger than zero it is returning the
input it's like an identity function if
it's 0 the output is 0 so it basically
looks like that yeah and then if we have
such a function here just group these
terms together call it U and V we can
represent that as a computation graph
for example if we would draw computation
graph of this equation would look like
this so we have again we have different
nodes here the nodes can be our data
points or let's say here scalars or rank
zero tensors and then the operations are
also nodes in the graph and then if we
multiply these two we get u it's one
thing in our computation graph then here
we add the bias we get V which is u plus
P and then we put it through the reloj
fashion to get a base or the activation
so that would be the same function that
we have here represented as a
computation graph and intensive flow if
we want to let's say define a
computation graph what we do is there's
always a default graph in the background
that we can add notes to but I prefer
usually to use it or to do it explicitly
to define a new graph use it as the
default graph and then add operations
and tensors to it and there are also two
kinds of things and tens of law where we
could to put data in first there's the
place holder you can see we don't put
any value here we just give it a shape
for input shape none that means basic
e-ring zero a scalar but we don't put
any number in here because the number
will be fed to the graph when we execute
the graph so they're in tensor flow two
steps defining a graph and running a
graph with an to run an actual
computation and if we just also define
this graph
it won't allocate any memory for the
graph if we have a let's say a large
matrix that's a thousand times 1000
elements this matrix doesn't get or the
memory for this matrix doesn't get
allocated until we initialize variables
and variables here variables in the
graph are things when we have a that's a
neural network and we have a weight
parameter or weight matrix these are the
ones that we want to change something
that we want to modify so placeholders
are more like data that we feed into
that could be you are into input data
and variables are the things that we
want to tune or optimize and these
variables have to be initialized when we
run the graph so we can I just put it
here a global variables initialize that
we will use it later that will
initialize variables and allocate the
memory for it and just to show you if I
would just run this print thing it won't
print any numbers it won't print the
number two and one here it will just
show us some definition see of our tenth
source so by that I just want to kind of
show you that it's not really running
anything any computation or it's just a
definition of a graph and to actually
run the graph we use a session so we
feed our graph to a tensorflow session
here and initialize the variables and
when we do a session dot run we can
fetch things from the graph and here B
doesn't have any dependencies we can
fetch the value of B by other session
but run here and get the one back that
we set earlier is the initial value for
variable B and the thing is here I put
it as a string here but you could also
easily say if I go back one slide you
can easily put the variable name be here
but what happened to me my projects is
often that I don't know by accident I
have multiple beasts for example if they
have a Python variable B also another
one and then it becomes Rican fusing so
what I usually prefer to do I give my
notes names for example here B and then
I use the name that is there in the
graph to be really explain
said that this is a thing from the graph
here and the : zero that so what you can
have is can have multiple beasts in a
graph and here in this case I only have
one B so it's the zero zero let's say B
zero and so you can have that's a B 1 B
2 and things like that so here you can
just ignore it it's just like let's say
like a counter or something like that
and yes so you can also what is also
pretty cool about it is what I found
useful to kind of debug my neural
networks is a tensor board it has to be
installed explicitly you have to call
pip install tensor board but what it
lets you do is it lets you monitor or
let's say wait parameters during
training the cost function I usually
don't do that because I run stuff on
HPCC so I write lock files but what you
can do is what I do then on my laptop
before I submit court with HP CCS I take
a look at my graph to see if it makes
sense if I didn't do anything weird the
connections don't make sense
so if I the previous graph that I showed
you of our function if I just add this
little file right here and a directory
well it's getting written too if I add
this I can then go to my terminal and
say 10 suppor Lockyer and give it this
directory head to my browser and then I
can also see the graph in my browser I
can interact with that if you have more
complex let's say networks you can
summarize certain things you can call
something like let's say you know
general neural network you can have the
generator and the discriminator
separately then you can expand looking
into it into detail you can interact
with it and things like that and as you
can see there are other things like
histograms and scalars you can monitor
things during training but here I use it
most of the time just to take a look at
my graph to see if it makes sense and
here that is exactly the same graph that
we define so everything is looking good
here it's the wait times multiplicate
multiplied by the input then we add the
page of it and put it through the realm
and yes so we can then also get multiple
variables from the graph here we can
feed
multiple variable names here I used the
UVA that I had in the graph I told you
that I usually a maybe forgot because
I've wrote it in PowerPoint but I
usually use the strings and another
concept that I want to mention here is
there's a feet dict and by that we can
feed their values to the graph so
remember X was a placeholder and to give
it a value we have to kind of there
multiple ways to feed data to the graph
but that may be the easiest most common
way while a Python to define a
dictionary and say we want to fit a feed
the value 3 to the X and then it does
the computation for instance here for
the you it would be 3 times 2 so we have
6 so it would give us back of 6 and for
the V we added 1 to it so it's 6 plus 1
is 6 and the reloj
just outputs X the input because it's
positive it's also 7 so we can see here
now we did actually the computation
before we just evaluated the variable B
we just forget got the value and when we
did that it didn't run all of this kind
of stuff it only runs stuff if I ask for
a it runs a but if I would let's say
remove a it would stop running here so
it doesn't run any unnecessary
computations and I think ya know it will
be a little bit yeah ok I will talk
about the religious I hope you like them
so because that's a very important
concept and why it tends to flow is kind
of useful because what I showed you
before you can easily do that in Python
so let's maybe briefly talk about
derivatives so here for example the
derivative of a with respect to B
basically if I change V a little bit how
much does it affect 8 it would be we can
write it down here just brought it down
here and I just will in the next couple
of slides right is the relative stone
for the other parts of my graph so for
each kind of connection here we can
define a derivative so how much does we
change if we change humor level or if
how does a little change in W affect you
so basically the derivatives but in a
real question in a real application of
neural networks what we have this is
just a simple example what we usually
have a cost function of something that
we want to minimize and we want to
change our weight parameters to kind of
minimize the cost function so we compute
the gradients which is just a vector or
of derivatives or partial derivatives
and then we take an opposite step into
the direction of the gradient to kind of
minimize the function yeah it's much
simpler it's just a simple graph we
don't have the cost function but just
list rate the point so usually in neural
network we want to change a lot of
parameters for example B and W with
respect to something or we at the very
end and here for example to get the
derivative of this function with respect
to B here we would use for example
something like the chain rule if we
would write it on a paper like in our
calculus classes so chain rule is
basically if we have a nested function
function f that takes a input G which
takes as input X and we want to know for
example how much does change in X affect
F so we would put a cicada kit down into
two parts
how much is f affected by changing G and
then how much is G affected by changing
its function argument X if we multiply
that we can basically compute the
derivative of the sole function f with
respect to X and this is kind of what
you usually do in on paper and calculus
classes but if you have a computation
graph I think it's much easier to
illustrate this concept using a
computation graph so here for instance
to compute the derivative of a with
respect to B so we can basically just
multiply these two parts so what we get
then is here the derivative of V with
respect to B times the derivative a with
respect to V so we basically say how
much does we affect a and how much is V
affected by B so putting that together
that gives us all my
is affected by a small change of me so
the derivative of that and we can do the
same thing here so here it's a little
bit longer we have three terms if we
expand it so if we look at it again
how much does w the small change in W
affect a and here we have this part and
this part and if we look at this again
so we we can expand think it's one too
much here
I made a little typo over there but it's
basically these two terms here we can
expand that and compute that and so if
we give it no actual values for example
if we just had our definitions here and
if we feed actual values to our graph a
3.0 for example like earlier we can walk
through a simple example looking at how
these derivatives look like and yeah
just have 3 times 2 6 6 plus 1 7 and the
reloj gives us 7 back and the real
function
I mentioned earlier is returning X if
something is positive and 0 otherwise so
the derivative of that would be here
simply 1 and here 0 because if we have X
in and it's all basically how much does
it affect what's the relationship
between input and output
it's a relationship of one or basically
the slope of the function would be one
and there would be a derivative of one
simply and for the next one we have
where are we here are here the question
like it's pretty small so how much does
its change of B affect the function B
and if we look at this we can simply use
the sum rule so here basically u becomes
a constant so and the derivative of B is
again 1 so we have 0 plus 1 equals 1
and we can do the same thing it's kind
of analogous so here how much does u
affect
we a small change here a piece a
constant because because it becomes zero
this one is again one and yeah a few
more here we have a multiplication we
have u times X so the derivative of that
would be simply X so we have three here
because the input is 3 so if I have a
function and I multiply it by X buts the
slope is basically X because X kind of
scales the fraction the last one and
here these are easy now because we have
computed all our intermediate steps so
we can just put it together one times
one it's one and we can do the same
thing here we could put a one and three
and one together which is three times
one minus one and yeah they're just
basically just to understand computation
graphs it's maybe a little bit of a
tedious exercise here but now getting
back to tensorflow to show you why this
is why tensor flow is also useful among
other things amongst I mean you of
course it's fast you can run it on a GPU
but also kind of show you some of the
convenience functions for example here
let's say I have my previous graph that
I defined earlier I can add more notes
to it here now I want to for example do
the same thing we did tediously by hand
compute the gradient our gradients
basically the derivative of a with
respect to W and the derivative of a
with respect to B and we can just use
for example the gradient function here
and if we feed it no value three we get
exactly the same values we get that we
did when we did this manually the three
for W and the one for B so that's cool
so tensorflow can automatically do that
so we don't have to analyze our networks
or cost functions and write everything
down manually like we would for example
doing numpy and just to kind of
emphasize the point tensor flow there
are two things usually when we write
tens of
codes code there's the graph we define a
graph and then we run or execute the
graph in a kind of session here just a
summary so we have basically two steps
which is kind of different from Python
because in Python when we do something
something like that u plus B it gets
evaluated immediately if it's getting
run here we really have to run it in a
session we have to initialize variables
feed a value to it and then it runs the
graph and it was previously a very
simple example of a simple computation
graph but in real life this is still a
very simple example it's just a
multi-layer perceptron with one hidden
unit and that is how except for example
how a forward pass would look like on a
very simple data set we have a
handwritten digit and we it's I don't
know 28 times 28 pixels we reshape it to
a long vector the column vector and then
we field here there would be basically
the an equal number 2 the input pixels I
have a very few nodes here to just fit
this onto the slide but that would
basically represent a very simple
multi-layer perceptron we get an output
then we compare to a class label define
a cost function and want to minimize
this cost function and let's just assume
we have a sigmoid activation here we
compute again this can be vectorized
it's just vector times vector
multiplication and we have an activation
function here the sigmoid and for the
output layer we have the softmax
activation give us the probabilities of
our output class labels and I went
through this exercise so I wrote all the
derivatives down here in a little bit of
a more compact form and actually this is
correct because I thought oh I assume
this is correct because a double check I
use the tensor for gradient function I
got the same result so I think I did
everything correctly here but as you can
see it's very tedious to do all the math
and let's say if you use enough I
implement a neural network in numpy you
have to kind of compute your des Roches
and things like that but in terms of law
it's actually much more convenient there
are a lot of functions that can help us
with this
for example if
wouldn't use pencil for this actually in
terms of flow but I could do the same
thing in numpy everything I had on the
previous slides I brought it down here
like the Sigma H the error terms and
things like that then I compute the
gradients I have to kind of define
everything by hand that is a very
tedious approach but intensive flow so
here one last thing in the end I put a
train operation to minimize the cost
function I have all my things that I
want to update I group them together so
I can just run this as one kind of node
in the graph which I can do here in the
session if I Caltrain it will run with
updates but again it's still very
tedious so a more convenient approach
would be just use the gradient function
that we talked about earlier I can say
ok compute the gradients for me here and
here and then I just assign used assign
to update my previous ways and biases to
minimize the cost function I can do that
it is slightly more convenient but it's
still very like tedious to define all
the gradients manually so what's most
convenient in tents allows you to use
something that's why it's maybe called
deep learning library rather than linear
algebra library because they have a lot
of cool stuff in there like TF train
gradient descent optimizer if many more
optimizers in there atom and things like
that here we just give it a cost
function like here and that's about it
it will figure out all the connections
to our graph and minimize the cost
function with respect to the weights we
don't have to bother writing down
radians and updating variables manually
it will do that for us and then again we
can run sessions or run train and yeah
that's about it that's as convenient as
it can get I think and just to talk
about one more thing
umm tends to follow tensor flow layers
so tensor flow layers is I would say
rather new I think it was added in terms
of 1.1 or 1.2 like in May or something
like that and they make things even more
convenient so just to give you an
overview this is a screenshot from the
dev summit uhm tensorflow dev summit I
think it was earlier this year
and here's a summary of the different
things how tensorflow is organized or
going to be organized so previously in
the previous slides we use the Python
front and brought kind of low-level tens
of your code but there's also something
on top of it layers that predefined
common layers like a fully connected
layer convolutional ner for 2d
convolutions and things like that on LS
TM and things like that and on top of
that it's I think currently still in
progress but they're also adding Karis
2/10 of more directly anything in a
cleaned up version like because the
chaos right now is written was written
to support the annual dance-off law was
edit and I think a mixed net was added
here they use thin layers to implement
this more cleanly or elegantly in pencil
flow and they also have an estimator API
which is very similar to what we know
from psyche to earn it's not quite like
psychic learn but it has something
similar to a train and predict function
and on top of that I think they included
some in the 1.3 a little release when I
saw it correctly like Kent estimators
for example linear classifier
multi-layer perceptrons and things like
that so that we don't have to construct
them manually
they are also you can think of them like
in cyclic load will just take regression
or something or SVM or something like
that and yet that makes things even more
convenient for my experiments I usually
use just the Python front-end because we
do a lot of custom stuff but these are
kind of nice additions to it and just to
give you an idea how this tensorflow
layers thing looks like so here I just
wrote a fully connected layer myself so
before that I had to define that myself
and then I used that in the graph to
kind of because I want to write a whole
whole fully connected function all over
again in the graph I can just define a
function and then call it to create a
fully connected layer on my graph and
let's say tensorflow layers we can just
use the dense function here so it's TF
layers
that's equivalent to my fully connected
before so it makes things much more
convenient and it's the same thing is
true for convolutional neural net layers
oh okay
so there are many more ways to feed
things into our graph and I just talked
about placeholders which is just using
Python or in Python we have a session
dot run and give it a Python dictionary
with things and it feeds stuff from the
Python session into the tensor flow
graph there are many more or more
efficient ways if you want to really
optimize your neuro networks um there
are the TF records files it's a based on
protobuf protocol buffer by developed by
Google a binary format which is kind of
efficient for storing data and let's say
weight parameters and models and also
they have queues which are very useful
if we work with large datasets one issue
is usually that the GPO waits it has an
operation and then we waits for the next
it's a data record or batch of images
it's kind of not taking full advantage
it's kind of starving the GPU of data or
things like that and having a queue it
kind of queues up things in the cache
and then it run basically directly fed
into tensorflow without you using the
feet in Python which makes things even
more efficient I played around with that
but usually I use hdf5 or with Python or
feed X because yet I'm it's not that
much of an issue if it runs let's say in
one day or one 1/2 days because I have a
lot of things to run and I use usually
these formats because they are more
because I don't only use tensorflow I
use other tools and these are more like
a common language that I can also use in
other tools and I just wanted to mention
though the other options unfortunately
yeah we are the thing we don't have that
much time left so I looked at my
abstract and I saw that I mentioned
general adversarial networks and when I
was preparing my talk was a Monday or
Tuesday I realized I was really running
out of let's say I'm at site 51:58 I
wasn't really having time for that
yeah I apologize if I didn't kind of
fully cover everything I promised I
would cover but I have this yeah github
repository where I put a general
adversarial networks in there you can
check it out it's I haven't had much
comments but if you want to look at it
it's there and yet to maybe wrap it up I
there are some additional free resources
I think a great book is the deep
learning book by in good fellow your
shell banjo and erinkoval
and this is free online the manuscript
is free you can read it for free there's
a paperback that you can buy but it's a
really great book which it may check it
out online if you like it if you want to
learn more about deep learning and if
you like it you can then get the
textbook and paper form of things like
that there's of course the tensorflow
documentation I think it's still the
best documentation there are a lot of
resources out there but I think they got
a little bit outdated over time because
tensorflow is involving this is the
official resource they have a lot of
tutorials I would I would say start
there because everything is kind of up
to date and very complete and very
thorough and yeah I also was it is a
busy summer I'm writing on three papers
in parallel two are getting submitted
tomorrow but if I have time I also
sometimes write on this book and it's
not really like about tensorflow it's
about deep learning explaining it
running at the end of each chapter there
will be it's a lab section where I have
tens of for examples that I explain a
little bit to kind of make the debriding
park more practical and yeah I'm
uploading right now I already have a
bunch of appendices but I'll upload
chapter also yes let's say a draft
version on github so it will be free and
things like that and yeah another
announcement another book was I said a
busy summer I didn't do the cover they
said it's a new serious it they call it
expert inside and they will all have
author images on the cover so I couldn't
do much about it
I hope you
you can even get the digital version you
don't have to watch it I'll see it on
the bookshelf it's annoying but anyway
so yeah I was also working on the second
edition of my machine learning book
which came out in 2015 it was actually
we started in February and each chapter
go to slight overhaul I addressed all
the reader feedback and at more
explanations fixed all the nasty typos
that came up during layout because you
had to write things in word they
converted to PDF and then a lot of typos
krypton maybe I also made some typos I
mean I'm only human
but we try to remove all the typos in
the previous version edit my
explanations I overhauled the figures
which I back then just created in
PowerPoint
I had to write one chapter a week I
think it was pretty rough so this time I
had a little bit more time to make the
figures nicer and this is actually one
of my collaborators by Natalie with him
I'm working on the biometrics project
and also he volunteered to contribute to
new chapters on tensorflow and
convolutional neural networks and
recurrent neural networks so will be new
chapters I think it will probably be 550
or 600 pages and we are currently
working I was just checking drafts
yesterday so it's still in progress but
it will be odd maybe in two weeks or
something like that and yeah with that
snow - maybe just the resources so again
slides are here I have a github
repository with all the code snippets I
had in here thing you can also just
still you can just execute them it will
all run fine I hope and ya know then
maybe for the maybe have five minutes
for questions so first of all thank you
for coming and it has been a hell of a
week a lot of work and it was fun I am
glad that I'm here and I enjoyed it and
was talking about a fresh topic I've
never talked before so I hope it was
kind of not too weird I hope you like
questions hopefully you'll share this
deck with us and that we can upload it
to her sure and it's already online so
you can either go on from there I can
give you a PowerPoint whatever you
prefer
and and thank you again Sebastian and I
want to say that I'm looking for artwork
on top of my mantle so I'm definitely
gonna use that book cover any questions
yes I think I also I know what you mean
it's like a circle and it's going from
the noise hmm I would just go through
this light quickly then we can yep so
you mean this part honestly I don't know
hey it works fine I think it's just
saying this has an init function I
honestly I also that looks a little bit
confusing and weird right I know if you
have multiple unit functions you can add
multiple units for example that's one
reason why I put my in it put it here
because but then the arrow should be the
other way around
maybe so for example if I wouldn't put
the init up here but I would often you
see it awesome tutorials you can take
this part and you can call it in the
initializer here in the session run put
this part here and then if you run the
recession multiple times and then you
look at the graph you will see then for
example it has multiple of these units
so I think it's just yeah like you said
a dependency but I'm not sure why the
arrow is going this way I'm not the
other way but you know actually wouldn't
even need an arrow I think it would just
be a line would be fine but I didn't
design this
[Music]
as far as I can tell there are some
models by Google like inception they are
pre-trained networks well I think that's
different I honestly haven't used that
can estimate us they just came out like
two weeks ago and once it's point three
but it looked to me they are more
similar to scikit-learn yeah it's not a
pre-fitted thing let's say it's an SVM
like ants I could learn you give it your
data and runs from your data it's not
like pre-trained or things like that
it's more like for common things that
say linear regression logistic
regression linear SVM you don't need to
reinvent the wheel and implement it
yourself someone already did it in a
nice way and it's just like a predefined
it's a estimator so yeah general
adversary networks so they are basically
you can do you can use it basically to
build a better predictor or
discriminator like a classifier but you
can generate new training data sets or
training samples so you basically have a
classifier to classify whether something
is let's say a generated image or a real
image of let's say a handwritten digit
and then you have an adversary that
generates something and once it wants
the classifier to think what it
generated is real like a real
handwritten digit and this community
becomes better at recognizing fake
images but then the so the generator has
to become better to fool it to make
better generated images so you can
basically generate new images with that
um of everything it's really hard to
train though handwritten digits is fine
but everything beyond that is I think
still experimental takes a lot of trial
and error
to get the right balance
because the cost function has two terms
the discriminator and the generator but
you can also improve basically a
classifier by generating new things and
making it more robust to things like
that in our project we used something
similar I don't want to talk to it too
much but for example we want to change
an image in a way to hide information
from the image for example and we don't
use generate force or networks like they
are we have some something else but yeah
well once the paper is I'll talk more
about that maybe baby the next time I
come here yeah sorry you mean this one
down here here that just means
element-wise multiplication if you have
a number of elements it's just like the
star and python like the esters sorry
yeah it's a little bit confusing here so
yeah basically if we have a training
data set that would be one pass over the
training data set so if we have let's
say 1,000 samples it would mean we
iterate about the 1000 samples it's one
iteration of the whole training set so
that's a good question
the question I saw tensorflow evaluates
that the root of at the kink of the
random function I'm actually not sure
how exactly it's implemented in
tensorflow
yeah could be so basically my question
if I had a custom step function so it's
not a built-in function and
to be what normally is in on the
valuable point what value would assign
when I take we use the gradient function
I've never tried that to be honest so
for the railway use the function as
early already implemented the question
was how would you define your own
stepwise function oh I've never tried
that how gradients works with that I'm
pretty sure if you look it up there's
one way someone tried that before
although no I did I think I did a lick
here a loop once I have to look at this
here yeah sample is a different way you
mean not the weight parameters but you
mean like importance of each sample I
think you can just have another vector
in your network if you have your network
let's say just encode you had another
vector to you know do an element element
wise multiplication of maybe your
predictions you've let's say you predict
values you multiply it with your weight
and then it gets taken care of in the
cost function because then if you have a
wrong prediction if you multiply it by
something positive if it's more wrong
you know so any other questions
great Oh what are the bad one walk
he's trying to start wars yeah so like I
said in the beginning I mean I just
checked all tensorflow I really liked it
the question was how it does compared to
let's say Theon oh but there's also that
say pay torch and how it makes things
easier I think honestly what I like
about is there's nothing I reckon say
that is much better or different but
it's such a common tool there's a large
community active mailing list a lot of
documentation a lot of people use it
it's like the X I could learn it's
nicely program but through the large
community of a lot of resources if you
need something it's easy to find it's
not much different from Theon I would
say I think it maybe makes a difference
if you put stuff into production I'm
just doing research I don't worry about
it but they for example have functions
that help you to run the code on let's
say a smartphone to port it to the
smartphone and also for distributed
computing if I usually just run my code
on one GPU but they have distributed
computing that you can utilize multiple
GPUs for one neural network you have to
do something something extra you have to
define which operation runs on which GPU
but yeah I'm not sure if you can do that
in Theano but these are things maybe
more like for production or things like
that but I think for basic stuff it's
not much better and I'm also surprised
why it's so much more popular than
Theano maybe because Google I don't know
so with that I welcome everybody to
stick around a bit longer network
interact and don't forget that there are
people hiring so definitely reach out to
them and so let's all give Sebastian
another round of applause
[Applause]